durante años fue el segundo al mando de
al qaeda la mano derecha de osama
bin-laden el ideólogo que guío uno de
los grupos terroristas más relevantes
del mundo nacido en egipto en 1951
ayman al-zawahiri creció en un suburbio
de el cairo con diversidad de religiones
y de clase media-alta tuvo una juventud
afortunada pero en su adolescencia llegó
a los escritos de uno de los fundadores
del extremismo islámico y se radicalizó
en 1981 fue detenido junto con docenas
de jóvenes por estar involucrado
presuntamente en el asesinato del
presidente anwar al-sadat
pasó tres años en prisión antes de
convertirse en el líder de la yihad
islámica egipcia una organización que
después se fusionaría con al qaeda se
cree que al zawahiri conoció a bin laden
en afganistán en la década de 1980 los
dos empezaron a trabajar juntos su
primer gran ataque fue el bombardeo de
las embajadas estadounidenses en kenia y
tanzania en 1998 pero no fue hasta el 11
de septiembre de 2001 que el mundo
conoció su nombre al zawahiri fue el
cerebro detrás de los ataques que
mataron casi 3000 personas y que
propulsaron eeuu a una guerra de décadas
contra el terror a pesar de una intensa
persecución siguió apareciendo de forma
regular en vídeos y dirigiendo
operaciones cuando asesinaron a bin
laden en 2011 al zawahiri se convirtió
en el líder natural de al qaeda bajo su
dirección el grupo terrorista cambió al
qaeda se fraccionó y se crearon otros
grupos afiliados como en yemen y en el
norte
grupos que intento mantener a raya en
los últimos años al zawahiri se fue
distanciando y se dedicó a escribir
libros y ensayos su última aparición en
vídeo fue en septiembre de 2021 cuando
volvió a pedir una renovación de las
violentas tácticas de al qaeda en el
mundo